kennt ihr diesen moment in dem einem
etwas sonnenklar wird letztlich hat sich
diesem moment und das verrückte auch in
der wissenschaft gibt es genau diese
theorie
wir wissen bereits was die dunkle
materie was ist die auflösung jetzt bei
klick zum 250
herzlich willkommen manchmal ist
eigentlich alles sonnenklar es ist alles
gar nicht so kompliziert sondern ganz
einfach und damit es einfach bleibt ist
dieses video ein gedankenexperiment das
heißt ich gehe einfach mal ein paar
vielleicht verrückten ideen frei nach
und da wo es theorien hypothesen oder
eine wissenschaftliche arbeit dazu gibt
er wenig und wenn es keine arbeit dazu
gibt denke ich trotzdem einfach mal
weiter der gedankenblitz kam mir als wir
hier die vielen videos über schwarze
löcher das holografische universum und
so weiter gemacht haben ein wichtiger
moment war das video wird das frei umher
fliegende schwarze loch die frage oder
besser idee was wäre wenn das ganze
universum voller schwarzer löcher wäre
viel mehr als wir zur zeit vermuten was
wäre wenn der hauptbestandteil des
weltalls schwarze löcher werden
auf diese idee hin machte es bei mir im
moment dann müssten sie ja die dunkle
materie sein warum
ja das ist eigentlich ganz einfach womit
wir dabei während das plötzlich alles
ganz einfach wäre die dunkle materie ist
ja mit ihrer gravitation dafür
verantwortlich dass ich kann aktien
anders verhalten als sie würden wenn sie
nur aus materie bestehen würden
die sternensysteme am äußeren rand
bewegen sich viel schneller als erwartet
also wenn nur die sichtbare materie
fahnden mehrere aber genau dieses
verhalten könnten schwarze löcher
verursachen sie kennen wir schon und wir
wissen sehr genau was sie verursachen
nämlich genau das und wenn man sich ob
wikipedia den ersten satz zur aktuellen
beschreibungen der dunkle materie
ansieht dann ist das eine absolute
erleuchtung zitat dunkle materie ist
eine prostituierte form von materie die
nicht sichtbar ist aber über die
gravitation wechselwirkt und auch was
griff genau diese beschreibung zu exakt
auf schwarze löcher um das würde auch
erklären warum die seltsamen teilchen
der dunklen materie nie gefunden wurden
und jetzt kommt es gibt eine
wissenschaftliche arbeit dazu
die ich dann bei der recherche gefunden
habe
genau das vermutet auch wissenschaftler
alexander kaczynski vom goddard space
flight center der nasa hat im letzten
jahr eine studie dazu veröffentlicht und
die ist simpel und einfach mein blut
seine these in den ersten sekunden
unseres universums direkt nach dem
urknall haben sich als erstes die
schwarzen löcher so genannte prix
mondiale schwarze löcher gebildet sie
bilden die dunkle materie und haben
überhaupt dafür gesorgt dass die materie
die nicht in sie gestürzt ist sterne
systeme und galaxien bilden konnte
sie war nämlich eigentlich zu heiß dafür
die schwarzen löcher haben sie durch
ihre gravitation er so komprimiert dass
sie gestirne bilden konnte diese studie
macht sich zum anliegen verschiedene
ideen und beobachtungen zusammen zu
bringen und zu untersuchen wie gut sie
zusammenpassen und sie passen
überraschend gut sagt kaczynski denn
dass alles korrekt ist dann sind alle
galaxien eingeschlossen unsere eigenen
in eine gewaltige fähre von schwarzen
löchern eingebettet von denen jedes rund
30 mal massereicher ist als die sonne
die größten schwarzen löcher und die
durch das verschmelzen von weiteren
schwarzen löchern entstanden sind haben
dann materie um sich gesammelt und so
die galaxien gebildet wenn das so ist
lässt es für mich nur einen schluss zu
und hierfür gibt es keinerlei
untersuchung studien oder sonstige
wissenschaftliche arbeiten das gesamte
universum ist auch nur das innere eines
schwarzen loches und das ist sogar
verdammt logisch denn was beobachten wir
hier im universum zahlreiche schwarze
löcher enthalten millionen und
milliarden sterne
das sind mengen an gestirnen die eigene
galaxie bilden würden und in diesen
mengen flora eigene universen
ermöglichen würden wenn jetzt die these
von holographischen universums stimmen
würde würde dass er genauso für diese
schwarzen löcher gelten der ereignisse
von der schwarze löcher ist eine
zweidimensionale oberfläche die die
dreidimensionale welt im inneren
lediglich projiziert im inneren wurden
lebewesen genau das gleiche erleben wie
wir und der blick auf stall den urknall
bei ihnen und
es wäre kein blick in die zeit zurück
sondern lediglich auf die singularität
in der mitte des schwarzen loches zeit
wäre keine abfolge von ereignissen
sondern die ausdifferenzierung der
projektion in immer mehr details durch
beobachtung das wäre genauso wie der
zoom an die grenze der mandelbrot menge
es gibt immer mehr details zu sehen aber
es endet einfach hier genauso wie wir
die zeit erleben und wo wir gerade bei
der mandelbrot menge film genauso könnte
die welt aufgebaut sein
nachdem immer selben prinzip entstehen
welten die immer kleiner werden diese
mathematik spielt zb bei pflanzen oder
unseren blutbahnen eine wichtige rolle
wird immer dieselbe regel angewandt bis
in die letzte spitze beim baum beginnt
es mit dem stamm dann kommen die elfte
wie immer wieder abzweigen und immer
kleiner werden und dann immer wieder
kleiner werdende zweige genauso könnte
sich mit den schwarzen löchern verhalten
wir leben in unserem universum in einem
relativ dicken art von ihm zweigen
mittelgroße fr ab das sind riesige
schwarze löcher in denen sich kleinere
universen mit kleineren schwarzen
löchern befinden und so weiter und wir
sind mit unserem universum in einem
größeren schwarzen noch das wieder in
einem größeren schwarzen loch ist und so
weiter
es macht absolut sinn weil unsere
gesamte natur so aufgebaut ist es ist
nämlich ein total sindler bauplan der
die komplexesten strukturen ermöglicht
wie gesagt räume die blutbahn unser
herzschlag überall ist dieses gesetz in
der natur zu finden
dann gäbe es nur noch eine frage die wir
wahrscheinlich absolut nie klären können
weil uns der blick auf ewig verwehrt
sein wird wie sieht der stamm aus also
das allergrößte schwarze loch und werden
dort alle fragen beantwortet damit ihr
nicht verpassen wenn hier weitere fragen
beantwortet werden wird mir hier ein abo
aufsaugen vergesst nicht die glocken zu
läuten damit ihr auch ja kein video
verpasst so weit mit dem einfach für
heute bis dann bleibt dran